Little saint, what's your background,
dude?
Um
Can you hear me? Yes, what's your
background?
So, I was I was baptized Catholic as a
a child.
And then I moved and went to Joel Osteen
church for like
What are you clicking? I'm sorry. That's
my pen. I'm sorry.
I want to I want to let you know ahead
of time I am slow and
I'm apologize like if I piss you off or
anything unintentionally.
>> I was born angry, brother. I'm angry
just just looking at the camera makes me
angry. So, what's up?
The
Yeah, so and I've been inquiring to to
Eastern Orthodoxy. All right.
After that guy
I've been reconsidering.
>> [laughter]
>> No, that guy's
that guy
listen
Online you have what they call they call
some Ortho Bros. They're the nastiest,
vilest, filthy, wicked
scum of the earth. They are a disgrace
to the Eastern Orthodox church. And it's
just not me.
I'm going to challenge you. Go to your
Eastern Orthodox church say
What do I do with these Ortho Bros
online? Okay. They'll tell you
[clears throat] stay away from them.
I know that personally cuz they've even
mentioned some of them by name and stay
away from them.
And I've met Eastern Orthodox priests
and deacons in my area and they tell me
stay away from them. They don't
represent us.
So, don't fall into their their nasty,
arrogant and they're not that
intelligent to be that arrogant. Cult of
personality, but nonetheless, brother
What's your question so I can see if I
can help you? Um so, it's quite a few. I
Keep it on the Trinity though. Remember
that. Oh.
What?
I I apologize. I thought when it said
Trinity and open question
>> as a Catholic. I didn't hear that.
He told me Joel Osteen. Oh, I didn't
hear that part. Yeah, I I'm sorry I
wasn't clear enough. I I heard you
saying you sent to a Joel Osteen.
Yeah. So, let me ask you, what was your
What drew you to the Eastern Orthodox
Church? Online community?
Yeah, I I was joining Do you know You
ever heard of Gideon?
Gideon?
No. Okay, well, it's just famous prank
YouTuber then he turned Christian and
and out of nowhere I was like, you know
what? I'm going to just give this a shot
and it's not a church I follow, but
Gideon?
>> there and and I started asking questions
about Book of Enoch and yada yada then
out of nowhere
>> told you he became a heretic, right?
He's one of that heretic.
He's not
Gideon, right? He's like that guy who's
like Don Young Don.
Yeah, I guess. I mean, I don't want to
make a judgment cuz I don't know as much
as anybody else.
>> a Trinitarian who loves and worships
Trinity from what I heard, no, right?
I guess not.
You guess not? You don't know, dude?
I don't know. I don't
I'm a bad man.
>> man?
I I I'll just finish the story. Let me
just finish the story.
Look at this guy here. He's telling me
Gideon's a legend. So, a heretic who
denies
the Trinity is a legend. Okay, go ahead.
>> yeah, that he's not the main the he's
not the main focus. Like so
um
I didn't I started joining like their
studies, didn't really pay attention,
but I noticed they had an open VC and
and
>> Open who?
Um in Discord there's these things
called
VC, yeah. Okay, go ahead.
Discord that's a breeding ground for
cults, cult of personality. I stay away.
But go
Yeah, I was I was in a separate VC that
wasn't the study and they had a an
Orthodox guy that was
like
um providing stuff and they were like
against it, but I guess I was draw
drawn in because of the simple question
of like the Book of Enoch. And then and
>> What about Enoch, though? I don't I
don't really care about it anymore.
>> Okay, so you get to the next level. We
heard Enoch. You went there because of
Enoch. Yeah, okay.
Um
and
yeah, and then I just started hearing
the humility and and uh of of the
Orthodox and and everything and like as
a person that's like I'm glad you met
the right Orthodox that represent their
church and not the Orthobros cuz they're
anything but humble.
Go ahead, yeah. No, that's the point. Do
you think I'm lying, man? I'm telling
you they're nasty, dude.
I don't know. I mean Stay away from that
group. Okay.
>> Just like you have nasty Catholics like
the militant Thomist, arrogant jerks. We
got jerks everywhere, but what So what
happened then? Continue.
Um in what sense do you mean, like like
Okay, what happened then? You Okay, so
because you're here to ask me questions.
So then you went you heard that. What
happened? What's next?
>> Yeah, and then it was just uh I started
to get I I was drawn to the faith and
then the drawn drawn to the faith and I
got closer and closer. The guy would
stay up with me all night and like
The yeah, the guy would stay
>> influence on you is what got you to
consider Orthodoxy. Yeah, and and he
helped me find um
a Greek or
>> So what if you had found a Catholic who
influenced and spent all night with you?
Then what would have happened?
I don't know. I think
So if you went to a I'm going to be
honest if I'm going to be honest, like I
guess probably I'd be judgemental and I
I wouldn't I I wouldn't give it give
them a chance, but who who knows? Maybe
>> You would not give someone a chance
because he's Catholic. So what's your
bias and hatred for the Catholic Church
that caused you I don't I'm saying this
was back then. This was back then.
>> Yeah, but you said you went to an
Orthodox
and because the Orthodox spent all day
with you answering questions, you're
drawn to it. So, what if you had gone to
Discord, met a Catholic who spent all
night with you and was kind and
compassionate? Okay. What would have
happened?
>> And then if then that then I probably
would have been drawn there then. So,
then you just testified against
yourself. Let me explain what I mean.
Okay. You're being drawn to a church for
the wrong reason.
You're being drawn because some person
showed you love and compassion as he
should.
Okay.
>> And because he belonged to a particular
group, that made you prone to now want
to look into it. Now, what's my point?
Of course, these churches are all
ancient. They are all part of
the historic church established by the
apostles. Sadly, they're in schism.
But the point is that's not a reason to
join any church because some guy showed
you love and compassion and he belonged
to this group, so I now want to
entertain the thought maybe that group
is true. You need to do due diligence
and study.
Because you said somebody hear you. You
said you were baptized a Catholic. Yes.
So then, what you did was you left the
church you did not know.
Yeah.
>> And now you're coming back to the truth,
the Trinity,
and you're now looking for the ancient
churches, but you never gave your
Catholic roots a chance.
Because you just jumped into a Discord,
someone who's Orthodox, and God bless
him.
Because he's part of a true church. But
to say that this is the only church and
these other ancient churches are
corrupt, no, that's not true either. So
then, instead of rushing into the
Orthodox church, you need to now take a
step back. Okay. You need to now go
listen to the best the Catholic church
has to offer by way of defense of their
doctrines, as well as Oriental Orthodox.
Then when you hear,
say, "Hmm, you know what? The evidence
seems to point this way." Well, see, um
the
that was
that was before.
Like, it's different it's different now.
know
>> it's different now, because how much
time have you spent studying the
Catholic side of things? And name the
sources and the people that you studied
from.
Uh
I couldn't tell you.
So, what's different? You're still
ignorant. Um yeah.
I'm far worse than ignorant, stubborn.
>> that's what I'm saying. So, what's
different? So,
um
you might laugh, but um I
>> dude. I Okay, okay. I'm just saying I'm
just saying I'm sorry. But go ahead.
>> My
um I was there and
>> Uh I went to the Orthodox church and and
everything and the the presence and
everything was insane. And then And so,
if I give you testimonies of people went
to the Coptic church and the presence
there was insane and blew them away, or
people went to Catholic church and
started balling like babies cuz the
presence there was insane. That's
subjective.
What are
the sources you studied from the
Catholic side
to make the best case for the Catholic
position?
Who are they? What are the sources? And
how much study have you done on the
other side?
Uh I haven't I really done any study.
>> don't care about your subjective
experience. That's what I'm trying to
get at. Meaning, it may be true for you,
but it doesn't mean it's
what determines truth, because here you
go, buddy.
Proverbs 18:17. I'm not dissuading you
from being Eastern Orthodox. Okay, I I
was confused. I was like I don't know
what you're talking about.
>> dissuading you from going by
feelings
>> to present his case
when you were already baptized in the
Catholic church and did not consider,
let me see why Catholics believe what
they believe and hear their best side
before I jump the gun. Because I want
you to read Proverbs 18:17 for me.
Okay. The first to plead his case
seems right until another comes and
examines him. So, you heard the first
case and you're convinced
maybe the other side that came and then
asked the right questions to get you to
slow down and say, "Hold on. You sure
you want to make this step? Have you
heard this and this and this and that?"
>> I I would I'd actually like to keep
going with the story and and
um and maybe But you never told me who
the other side was that you heard from.
Uh
it's for Catholicism. Name some of them.
Even though the topic's about the
Trinity, I'm still waiting for those
names.
I don't know any Catholic people. Like I
I was going to name like Brother how I
You don't know any Catholic people. You
found someone online. Yes. Yes. The
YouTube world and Discord have plenty of
Catholics and Oriental Orthodox
channels. Yeah. Who did you go to to
hear the other side of the story?
Like
in what
I'm so sorry, sir.
No, it's all right. I'm sorry, bro. I'm
sorry I was born into this world, but
God have mercy on me.
Who's the other side of the coin? Which
Catholic apologist theologians, which
Oriental Orthodox Catholic theologians
you listened to
to hear how they would respond and what
arguments they make for their position?
Uh I don't think I can't recall any. You
haven't, brother. That's my point.
So
whatever is in my face What? It It's
more like whatever just shows up in
front of me.
>> Exactly. But then read this verse again.
Okay. The first to plead his case seems
right.
Until another comes and examines him. So
why don't you follow God's counsel and
go hear the other person examining
your
uh case that you heard from the first
guy.
Go listen, man, and then make your
journey, brother. Because here it just
tells you
Anyway, sounds convincing and right
when you hear them until you hear
someone else and they bring some
objections and challenges. Oh, wow.
It's not as airtight as I thought.
So, is this
is this verse explaining
the both both lines? Is it explaining a
flaw, or is the second one
>> a flaw Okay. that you just jump in
headfirst because you heard
the a position articulated by someone
without having him being cross-examined.
Cross-examined. Okay.
It You understand that? What it means
the first to plead his case seems right?
Because he goes unchallenged, right?
>> a Can you give just to drill it in for
me? I do best with analogies. Can you do
that? For me. I'm sorry. Yeah, the
analogy, brother, I just told you.
I come and I make a case for my
position.
Right. And you sound persuaded. Yes.
Yes. But, you've never heard someone
then come and challenge my position to
see if my position can stand. Okay. I I
actually have something for you, but
it's not in a sense where
>> do it. It's for you, man. It's not Okay.
Yeah.
>> It's for you, not for me, cuz you just
kept saying I don't know if you're
listening to yourself.
You have not heard the best
>> I need to hear the the Catholic side of
things.
>> And the Catholic or in the Orthodox,
they're also in the equation as well.
Okay. Okay.
Have you heard the best from both sides,
especially I've heard Oriental. I've
heard Oriental, and I love them also.
Well, I don't know how much you can love
them because
if you love them that much, then you
didn't tell me you're considering
Oriental Orthodoxy. You said Eastern
Orthodoxy.
So, I mean
I Well, I've been I've prayed to God to
This is This is what has been my prayer.
I've won the pull on my heart so far,
like so strong that even if my brain
says the other direction, I get dragged
to go Christ direction. No, that's
actually the opposite. Your emotions can
deceive you.
And your emotions can override what your
mind sees to be the truth. I'm cooked.
Buddy, that's opposite. How many times
have you done things because of your
emotions that you knew was a mistake and
regretted it?
All the time.
So, notice what you just said. I want
the pull on my heart to be so strong
that it doesn't care what my mind
thinks. Right. You want your emotions to
drown out your mind.
But you just said, I want you to listen
to yourself.
There are times in which you let your
heart
drag you into things that you knew were
wrong or regretted later.
Yes.
So, what a stupid prayer, dude.
See how you prayed?
You don't get more stupid than that,
man, that prayer. I told you I'm
bro. Huh?
I told you I'm slow. That's okay,
brother. I'm slower than you, bro. Sure.
No, I'm slower than you.
Okay.
>> Here, read that verse for me, man.
He who trusts in his own heart is a
fool.
>> [laughter]
>> You're stupid, bro.
It reminds me of
Jeremiah 17:9.
Yeah, but no, he who trusts in his own
heart is a fool, bro. But he who walks
wisely will escape. You don't go by what
you think and feel. You go by what the
facts are as they're presented to you.
So,
so I pull
from intellect, I guess.
You know, you're letting your emotions
override your mind. As you just said,
the presence is strong. Of course it's
going to be strong. It's a true church,
man.
Okay.
>> the presence won't be strong? It's a
true church.
Of course God's presence there. Right.
But I guarantee you if you go
to Oriental Orthodox church, you go to
these other ancient churches, Catholic
church, especially if you go to Latin
Mass, you're going to sense the same
presence in a marvelous, miraculous way
cuz they're all part of Christ, his
presence.
>> I love it, too. Like All right. So, then
don't let that be the determine
determining factor. So, start your
journey. Go now watch the best Catholic
websites making the best case for their
position. Go to your into Orthodox,
pray, and keep going to the churches and
visit them. And then when you see, "Wow,
the arguments they made
for [snorts] why
the Filioque is wrong, baby's wrong.
Man, that's very strong. Wow, the
arguments they made for them being true
stronger. Then
jump on board, all right?
>> I I have a question for that that uh I
don't know if I answered but go ahead.
Um
so
uh
whenever you was explaining like like uh
I apologize if I misuse your words, but
like the uh
me finding me looking at both sides of
things, right? And and I guess using
intellect of dumb guy like me, but just
trying your hardest
>> You're not too dumb. You're here, right?
That means that was a smart decision.
You're not as dumb as you look, but go
ahead.
Um
okay, I have more to to look into now
more